[Applause]
this is goodbye to the woman many in
germany have called muti or mother
and welcome to the man who has the tough
task of filling her shoes
[Applause]
olaf schultz wore to fulfill his task as
chancellor after his appointment was
rubber stamped by mps now the so-called
traffic light coalition of social
democrats liberals and greens can get to
work
i'm looking forward to the new job i'm
looking forward to everyone working here
and today marks a good start for our
country
in schultz's hometown hamburg batchat
algon celebrates this special day with a
discount for an olaf schultz haircut
a little joke from the barber who
happens to be an old friend they met
each other and both were working for the
sbd the social democratic party
it's a special day because my good
comrade my very sensible convert will be
in a powerful position as chancellor and
i will keep my fingers crossed
i can't even explain how special this
day is for me
schultz will lead a three-party
government with the greens and the
liberal fdp a novelty in germany the
coalition has announced an ambitious
177-page deal that should modernize
germany by speeding up the energy
transition and improve welfare provision
but it's the deadly fourth wave of the
coveted pandemic that will need all his
attention first we need to be able to
make the decisions fast and that also
means he has to lead the coalition and
not go into endless debates and and
compromises with half of his cabinet
posts given to women charles wants to
show he is serious about change his
foreign minister annalena berbock of the
greens has announced the toughest stance
on russia and china but some wonder if
scholes has what it takes to lead
internationally i think his lack of
charisma is a weakness
now
his uh his advisors keep telling us that
this is going to be a strong chancellor
that can bring people together and that
behind the scenes he is the person that
can do that but certainly he hasn't
shown that he can convey
and can bring people behind him germany
will find out soon enough because the
country takes over the g7 presidency in
january an important moment for schultz
to convince those who still have doubts
all eyes are now on this man all of
joel's has promised a new era for
europe's largest economy but with
germany in the grip of the covet 19
pandemic and tensions at europe's
borders his term is off to a challenging
start
a new dawn for germany angela merkel
will watch it all from the sidelines it
might take a while until germany will
get used to that step farson al jazeera
berlin